- [Interviewer] All right, all yours.
- My name is Pete, but I'm
called in Skid Row, Repeat,
because when we have an
encounter you wanna do it again.
If you're on the right side.
And what I mean by the right side is,
if you're not bullying somebody,
or putting somebody down
because they're less
fortunate than you are
then I consider that the right side
because I'm a K9 (indistinct),
a K9 (indistinct)
is a level of the underdog.
I like the person who has
the least chance of winning
because that's how, I went
through life like that,
having the least chance.
But I started winning
somewhere along the line.
Anyway, before I went into the Navy
I had got my 70 Buick
Skylark when I was 16,
got a 67 Chevy, low rider,
hydraulics the whole works,
things would go wrong with the car.
I couldn't afford to pay
a mechanic to do things
now at this time, where
sometimes they didn't want to
because I liked the money in my pocket.
So I would go out and I would steal cars.
I got good at it, I got real good at it.
I got so good at to where most of the time
I would sit there and I would time myself.
Sometimes I knock on your door,
and wave at you and walk to your car,
get in before you got outside I was gone.
The longest it took me at
that time was like 18 seconds.
And I've considered that slow.
I'd be in the car and I'm gone
by the time you run out in
your drawers with your gun
I didn't care what it was.
It was like a adrenaline test to me,
like a move to manhood,
and I got better at it.
I also got better at the mechanics.
I couldn't afford to pay a mechanic
so I had to do it myself.
And when I look at cars,
it's like I am looking at a
puzzle where I take it apart.
And I remember how it goes back together
as I take it apart.
When I was younger, seven or eight years,
I used to take the TV apart.
I couldn't always get it back together
but I knew how that was supposed to go.
My mom got kinda mad at me
for taking the electronics
apart in the house,
but sometimes I put it back
together before she found out.
So there's just a particular time to where
my brother had a lot of
money, and I had called him up
because I was at the low end of the scale.
And I told him, "Man,
I need some money, man,
or I'ma go out and I'ma do something.
So he said, "Look, just
meet me at mom's house."
So I met him at my mom's house.
Couple of hours later, he showed up,
he told me to get in the car.
And I thought he was just
gonna hand me some money.
Got in the car, and he drove.
We drove for like two
hours out to Lancaster,
hour and a half, whatever it takes.
And when we got to Lancaster,
we're in his house,
and the first time I ever seen his house.
I had never knew that this dude
had moved up to that level.
It was so beautiful, I mean I was amazed.
Large four bedroom, pool
in the back, marble.
I mean, I was looking at this stuff
and I knew what it costs
because I had went into
Fred Federated Store, a stereo store,
and they had the Macintosh system.
And the cheapest part of a Macintosh
was the $204,999, but
he had his whole system.
Anyway, he told me,
"Just relax, we're gonna
go get some money, right."
So a day went by, another day went by.
He got me brand new clothes and feed me.
And I'm getting kind of tired.
"When are you gonna give me the money
so I can go do my own thing?"
So he said,
"Okay look, we'll make
the move tomorrow, right."
So anyway, that evening he came
with a brand new Honda Accord
with a dealer's license plate on it,
he went and purchased it.
He took me downtown LA,
where I'm about now,
and we went to the
Japanese or the Chinese, or
we went to the Asian section
and he bought a Ninja suit.
He bought, you know, the whole hookup.
I'm tripping off of it,
and wondering what he gonna do.
So that night he gave,
he said his 38 is jammed,
so I took it apart,
I mean, at this time I
was good with weapons.
I took it apart, oiled it, cleaned it.
We went out in the desert and fired it.
Cleaned it again, put it back together.
That morning, we got in
the car and we took off.
We drove for like 18 hours, 19 hours,
20 hours, to somewhere around Oklahoma.
And we pulled up in a
certain area and he said,
"That's him right there."
So I looked around and
see who we talking about.
He said, "There, the green Cadillac."
So in the green Cadillac I seen a dude,
and he gets out, he go to
a bar and grill pool hall.
He opens it up, he goes in.
He said, "Yeah, he own that building.
That's his whole hookup right there."
He said, "Look, I gave
this dude a small fortune
and he owed me and he never paid me.
He keep telling me he gonna pay me
but he not giving it to me, fuck that."
He said, "We're gonna take him down."
I'm like, "All right, I'm good with that."
So he said, "Let me show
you something else."
We went to another part of town
and this is physically the
first time I ever seen police
in somebody's pocket.
What I mean by that is the
dudes were serving dope
and police sitting there,
and they not doing nothing.
I was amazed that they didn't
jump out and bust them.
Matter of fact, the
dude opened up his sack
on the police car, took some work out,
gave it to somebody, got the money,
and went back talking to the police.
I was like, "Wow, that's amazing."
He said, yeah, he got the whole force
like that in his pocket, right?
So he said, "Let me show
you where his sister live."
We went to his sister's place,
and he said, "He keeps at least two birds
in her kitchen under the sink."
A bird is a kilo, a
brick, a thousand grams.
He said, "He keep at least two of them."
A thousand grands at
this time was $25,000.
You'd make a $100,000 off of it.
You'd literally make
a $100,000 off a kilo.
So anyway, he say, "She keep two of them.
He keep two of them in her kitchen
and taped under the sink."
He said, "He also keep
one or two in his house
under the sink, but it's
outside in the garage, right."
So we went and we drove to
another section and we pulled up.
He said, "Okay, that's
his house right there."
He said, "This is what you're gonna do."
We pulled off.
He said, "I think he live by himself,
but you gotta check it out."
So we pulled off two or three miles.
He pulled over, he gave me the Ninja suit,
he gave me the 380, he gave me $500.
He said, "I'll see you when you get home."
He got out of the car and
he started walking away.
I just looked at him while he walked off.
After he got to the corner,
I knew he wasn't joking.
He turned the corner and disappeared.
So I'm looking around thinking,
"This motherfucker
think I'm gonna do this.
Okay, that's how he want it,
he want me to do it on my own.
All right, fantastic, I'll put it down."
So got in the driver's seat, drove around.
Now I remember the section
where the pool hall was.
So I went back over to that section,
and I watched the dude serve him.
They would go after they
served him till they sat,
they'd go over there to his bar and grill.
They come back out and
they start serving again.
So I knew those is...
work he had four guys.
So that night, when they
left the bar and grill,
they serve out of their home.
So I went to their house
and I didn't know him.
So I kind of waited down the
street till somebody came by.
I said, "Hey, you feeling to go down there
and get something?"
They say, "Yeah."
I said, "What's dude's name?"
And they would tell me his name.
I said, "Look, I wanna go with you,
I wanna get something for like a $100.
"All right, come on."
So I would walk with him.
I would go in, I would make a purchase
and let the dude see me a couple of times.
Then I went on my own.
I let the dude know that I was
gonna buy something larger.
I let them know that,
"Hey, my name is Chicago.
We trying to do something big.
If you can handle the weight
I'm gonna go ahead and start
purchasing bird for you."
These dudes wanting to excel,
they wanted to grow up.
All of them did.
So I went back to them, I
started shortstopping the people,
the people would have to walk like
two or three miles to get to a spot.
So I went down the road and parked,
and started serving them down the road
and I'd go down there
and buy some from them.
So I built up my clientele
through them for about nine days.
Every night I knew what
time this dude closed up.
So I would go sit outside the bar.
When he drive home, I'd follow him.
He'd go in the store, he'd
get a pack of Benson & Hedges,
get two forty-ounce of Old
English, and he'd go home.
And I'll follow him home.
The second time I followed him home
I jumped the gate and I took the trash.
I took his trash because
the trash would tell you
who an individual is, how
many people are there,
who lives there and so forth and so on.
So I took the trash and I went through it.
I know he lived by himself now.
I know there's no woman, no children
'cause he has no trash
for women and children.
There's no lipstick on his
cigarettes and anything else.
So I know pretty much
when he leaves for work
the house is empty.
So after about nine
days, I make a decision.
"I'm going to go and get this dude.
This is the night I'm gonna get him."
'Cause he's a creature of habit,
he was doing the same thing
the same way every time.
So the ninth day I went to go and get him
but I decided I'm gonna go in the house
I'ma find the money.
So he had a stucco stout house.
So I took a screwdriver
and dug the stucco away from no bars,
pulled the bars out, climbed
in and searched the house.
I searched the house for
about a hour, hour and a half.
And I found a sack of
money, but it was $1 bills.
It was just like 4,000 $1
bills off in the closet.
So I took it, I threw it back in.
That wasn't what I was there for.
I knew he keep anywhere from a quarter
to a whole meal ticket inside his house
from $250,000 to a million
dollars inside his house
'cause he never made deposits in the bank.
So I decided I'm gonna have
to take this the hard way.
I couldn't find the money.
So I had to wait for him to come home.
So I called my brother and I told him,
"Hey look, I'm finna make this jump
and take him down if I got to."
He said, "Look man, this dude is a killer.
If you slip, he gonna get you.
So if somebody's gotta go
it might as well be him instead of you."
I said, "all right, I got it covered."
I waited for the guy to come home.
He eventually came home,
and when he came through,
I had a ski mask on, I rushed him.
I rushed him like I was the police.
I handcuffed him, hit him in the head,
turned him over and told him,
"Hey look, you got one
chance to live through this,
tell me where the money is
or I'm gonna blow your
motherfucking brains out."
He told me it was in the
mattress in the bedroom.
I had felt the mattress,
but I didn't feel the money.
So I went back, cut the
mattress, and there it was,
it was $186,000, 186 stacks
of thousand dollars bills.
Each stack with a $1,000.
I put them all in a bag, left the house.
But before I left the house,
I went back in and I got the
two kilos from under the sink.
So I got a $186,00 and 2 kilos.
When I leave the house,
jump in the Honda Accord
I hit the highway.
I'm doing about 110 'cause I'm happy
I got dizzy and a 110 miles
an hour on the freeway
with two birds sitting out,
and $186,000 on the driver's seat.
When I get back home I
don't run into my brother
for about a day, I'm trying
to catch up with him.
I don't run into him.
So at this time I go and I do another move
with $186,000 cash and two birds.
I go and do something else, I add to it.
I get another half a bird and $64,000.
So when I started doing it,
was I found it was easier
to start robbing the
people who sell the dope
than it was to rob.
I mean, it's not like
they was gonna go tell
or call the police and
say they got robbed.
Anyway, there was this one thing
that kinda went down bad.
Not that I had to hurt
somebody or somebody hurt me,
but it went South of the border.
It turned out that there
was a female in the house
when I thought it was a dude,
and she kind of surprised me.
She surprised me by walking in
when I thought the house
was supposed to be empty.
And I didn't put a whole in her per say,
but I almost did, close enough to it,
to where she backed up and fell out
the second storey window.
And when I looked out she was tangled up
in the bushes downstairs,
and she didn't die,
but she was injured real bad.
And I made a decision from that time that
that was the end of
that, I wouldn't be doing
what they call now home invasions.
I wasn't doing a home
invasion on people who
just the regular, you know, citizen.
I was doing a home invasion on the ones
who had the money, and I
knew they had the money.
And I would go in, and most of them were,
all of them, actually all
of them were dope dealers.
So I would go in and
I would liberate them.
Eventually I did plug somebody
but I'm not gonna really go into that
because there's no statute limitation
on a variety of things.
And that's not one of the
ones I'm going to go into
but I wish I wouldn't have.
I wish I didn't.
I never got pinned for it,
and probably never will,
because three people can keep a secret
if two of them are dead.
And that would be the only way,
so I did everything by myself.
I didn't take nobody with me,
if I did I probably
would've got rid of them too
unless it was an immediate family member.
But I'm not particularly proud
of a lot of things that I did.
And this was 15, 16 years old
when I really didn't have to do it, at 17,
I didn't have to do it,
but I did it any way.
I did it because it was
more of an exhilaration.
There was something to break the norm,
something to test my limited abilities
when I didn't think I was mortal,
I thought I was immortal.
But I found out when I
did go into the military
and got scrambled and got hurt,
it did hurt that I was mortal.
That pain was nothing compared
to what happened to me
about three weeks ago.
I was sitting in front of
a car in a lounge chair
and I had my feet out about 12 inches.
And a Hummer H2 came down the street
and actually ran over my foot.
And I'm only 12 inches out from the car.
My foot is 12 inches out.
He ran over my right foot,
and I heard a boom first.
And I thought he had ran over my shin
but it was only my foot.
And when he ran over my
foot, I couldn't believe it.
I didn't feel the pain immediately,
until I stood up and
realized what had happened.
And I looked down and
I could see the print
the Hummer tyres, the (indistinct) tryes,
I can see it in my shoe.
And I knew that same print was in my foot.
I knew my foot was shaped
like that, like a cartoon.
And I jumped up and my
girlfriend had said,
"Did that car hit the chair?
I heard a boom."
I said, "That boom was my fuckin' foot."
(laughs) I've never felt pain like that.
I fell down and I took my shoe off
and I looked at my foot and
it was like an accordion man.
And I pulled the other shoe
off just for a comparison,
and I looked at them, and the right one
is different from the left one.
He ran over my foot
literally broke my right foot
and two of my toes, and he kept going.
Police, ambulance, everybody came.
I cussed everybody out (laughs).
I fear God, but I was cussing Him out too
for letting it happen.
He ran over my foot, he broke it,
and I've never felt.
I mean, I used to walk
in the street blindly.
I used to just ride with reckless abandon.
Now when I walk in the street,
I stay on the sidewalk.
And when I cross, I look behind me
because that shit hurted.
And it still hurts now.
And it's been about three weeks.
I couldn't let 'em put a cast on me
because if they'd put a cast on me,
I would've literally starved to death.
Who would went and got my meals?
Who would have hustled for me?
I would have been in trouble.
So I kind of braved through the pain
and everything else and
limped where I needed to go
and limped to do what I had to do.
And I did a few things.
But when you live by the sword,
you die by the sword, you know.
It comes hard, and easy come, easy go.
And I appreciate the opportunity to
be able to divulge some things.
Some things are interesting.
other things are casual,
but here all you have to do
is sit back and look down the street
and you will see a movie unfold.
Something's gonna happen.
Skid Row, downtown Los
Angeles, this is where we at.
And I can appreciate being here
because once you,
what's the sign say?
I lived through the earthquake,
I've conquered this.
Once you lived through Skid
Row, you've lived, man.
You can live just about anywhere now
if you know the language.
But there's a Skid Row,
South Central Los Angeles.
And I appreciate your time.
I appreciate your attention.
And I appreciate our producer
for making this possible
for all of us to have a voice.
There's a racial issue that's going on.
And it's not a white and black thing.
It's a, I would say Mexican,
but that's kind of offensive.
I could say Latino, but then
that includes everybody.
But it's generally with the group
who consider themselves Southsiders,
from Southern California, and the blacks.
They got this stupid ass war going on
and it evolved from the prison.
I thought it was limited to the prisons.
I don't dislike people
races, I dislike a person.
If you dislike me, I dislike you.
There's this stupid ass
war going on in prison,
over something that's not yours.
"Okay, these our work out bars,
that's your toilet, this is our benches."
And it's nobody's.
But it's the cause of the separation.
And now they're doing it
30s, 40s, on the West Side,
they're doing this same stupid thing.
Mexicans or Latinos or whatever
you wanna refer to yourself as,
are jumping on black
people indiscriminately,
men, women and children.
And black people are jumping
on Mexicans indiscriminately,
men, women, and children.
One thing I know for
sure, being a black man,
we do not raise our children to hate.
We raise them to defend they self,
to stand up for they self,
but we don't raise them,
"Hey, you hate 'em
because they're Mexican.
You hate 'em because they're Asian."
No, we don't do it, the other races do it.
Especially the South side Mexicans
they're raising their
children just to hate us
because of color.
Not because they know us,
not because they had an incident with us
just because they hate.
So they're passing it on.
And it took me about 20 years
in prison to realize this
but they're raising
their children that way.
And I knew it was true
when I started hearing about racial riots
in junior high school.
It had to be done at an early age
for 'em to have racial
segregation in the schools.
Because when I went to
school, we weren't separated.
We was whole, we was a whole unit.
Football team, basketball
team, the whole school.
Now it's divided just like the
prisons and everything else.
"So united we stand, divided we fall."
And it's real, it's taking place.
And I was surprised hear
about it a couple of weeks ago
because I didn't know
what was taking place
till it was brought to me.
And I don't have the racial segregation.
I don't have the racial discrimination
in my heart and my soul
because I accept everybody.
I might not like the individual,
but I don't base that on the race
because there's only one race.
That's the human race.
And that's what I have to say.
- [Interviewer] Excellent,
thank you Repeat.
- Fantastic man.
Appreciate being here.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] So the
story you told about
robbing the dealers.
Did you finish that story?
Not about the who got shot
but what happened with all
the money that you got?
- See easy come, easy go.
I thought it was forever.
I was buying everything.
I bought a brand new motorcycles.
I bought a boat, my boat, my first boat
was a $58,000.
My second one is $126,000.
I mean I spent the money.
I spent it because I thought
I can always do this.
I thought it was so easy to do it again.
I may be pulled it off seven times,
and the lowest denomination
I got was like $64,000,
but that was easiest way
for me to make money.
It was easier than working a job.
All I had to do was sit
on the street and listen,
and find out who was where,
and where they lived and
watched them for a while.
And they were a creature of habit.
They do the same thing.
And when I can see their
method of operation
I figured out a way in, I
figured out how to do it.
I figured where I was gonna
get in, where I fit in.
And I was able to do it,
because all I did was start it out.
- [Interviewer] And you spent it all?
- Yeah, and it worked.
You know, that was the surprising part.
It didn't work exactly the way,
just like the military,
the Navy Air Force,
they have a perfect plan
until the first shot is fired.
And then everything's a cluster fuck,
it all goes to hell after
the first bullet is fired.
It never goes that way.
Always goes a different way.
But I tried to plan for X factors
and by God's will, I'm still here.
- [Interviewer] You look great too.
- Thank you very much, man.
So do you Mark, it's appreciated.
- [Interviewer] All right, thank you.
- [Repeat] You're welcome.